dear media
Representatives we will hear the views
first of Mr milatovic president of
Montenegro thank
you media
Representatives dear president of the
European
commission after a very substantive and
constructive meeting with the president
of the European commission miss
fion it is my pleasure to say that
after years I'd say of a rather passive
attitude towards the western balcan
region and a long period of
deliberations about the destiny of the
enlargement process these issues are
again on top of the EU agenda among
other things owing to the efforts of the
president of the commission so miss fine
I thank you for that in support of that
is exactly this visit today and a
session of encouraging messages that
President F Deion has
sent in her approach and action we see
true commitment to revitalizing the
enlargement
process in our discussion I have
emphasized again the important
comparative advantages that make
Montenegro closer or bring it closer to
the European Union as compared to other
candidate countries and that the
perspective of fully fledge membership
of our country of the EU even before
2030 is realistic and
possible Montenegro has practically no
open issues with its neighbors it is a
NATO member State since
2017 it is a small economy which for two
decades now bases its monetary policy on
the use of
Euro it has progressed the most in the
EU integration process compared to all
the other candidate countries it fully
aligns its foreign and security policy
with the policy of the EU and at this
point it has a truly
reformist or reform oriented political
majority all of that together is
something that no other country has that
is a candidate for EU membership and I
have emphasized this in my discussion
with the president of the European
commission for these reasons we believe
that membership of mon of Montenegro uh
in the EU would be a very good message
to all the other candidate countries
that the enlargement process is
alive which would be an additional
incentive for all the others to continue
even more strongly with the
implementation of the reform agenda that
should bring them closer to the EU I
wish to remind you all that uh in light
of everything that I've said we support
the regata
principle uh where uh individual
achievements of the countries will be uh
assessed uh in meeting the benchmarks
for EU membership I also wish to
emphasize the importance of the
presented growth growth plan for the
Western Balkans that the president of
the European
commission has uh presented a couple of
months ago and that we have discussed
additionally today which will tackle the
or move the uh uh enlargement issues uh
from dominantly political aspect to
equally as important economic aspect
opening the door to the integrated
European market deepening Regional
economic cooperation
with the planned increase of direct
financial assistance from the
EU will contribute to an optimal use of
pre accession assistance to economic
stability and ultimately it will
constitute an additional
motive for all to speed up the uh uh
essential reforms uh in their own
countries we have also discussed the
importance of revitalizing Iz ing the
Berlin
process which is very important for
Montenegro primarily in the context of
the new and additional confirmation of
presence and focus of the
EU uh on the uh region of the western
Balkans to that end I expect that in the
near future the new uh parliament of
monegro will ratify the obligations that
arise from the Berlin process and to
contribute fully to their
implementation I also wish to
say that I understand the critical views
of the EU expressed in the last year's
progress
report and the recently adopted
resolution of the European Parliament I
hope
that in this respect at the national
level we have learned our
lessons and that after quite a long time
of unsatisfactory level of uh Pace I
have to admit that this was the case I
hope that now the conditions have been
created for this process to speed
up in this context I believe that the
most important political actor primarily
the Parliament and uh the government
that was formed this morning will
recognize the importance of the
political moment when it comes to the
European perspective of Montenegro and
that with their constructive
actions they will allow for a full use
of
potential
generated through long awaited political
changes in the country that happened in
on this path the strongly expressed
views of the citizens in the
presidential and then parliamentary
elections uh serves as a clear
guidance for all of the uh political
actors in
Montenegro I wish to remind you that in
the previous challenging period which
was marked by instability among other
things difficult operation of key
institutions in montgo the focus of my
political action was consolidation of
the overall political economic and
social potential with the aim of
creating the necessary prerequisites to
uh meet the requirements for EU
membership as a key strategic goal of
Montenegro uh with regard to this goal I
have recently initiated and proposed a
joint platform for Montenegro in the EU
that I have additionally discussed with
president ferion today I believe that in
the near future the conditions will be
created to implement the key principles
that are mentioned there primarily
through ensuring the key factors uh um
in the monegan Judiciary actually uh
appointments in the Judiciary and its
overall uh structural reform finally let
me EXP Express once again
my um the commitment of Montenegro to
achieving its European goal which is
based
on strong shared values which was
clearly confirmed with its previous
actions emphasizing that this is far
from just words or unilateral or
interest based alignment with the views
and positions of the EU quite the
opposite this is uh based on our shared
values this is something that we did as
equals so we share the same values as
the EU and its member states that is why
100% alignment with the foreign and
security policy of the EU
shows uh also the geopolitical
positioning of monteno in these
challenging times and constitutes the
path that this country will definitely
follow
in the period to come Miss V thank you
for your visit and I look forward to our
new meetings thank you president
milatovic thank you I give the floor to
miss F now thank you very much Mr
President de Yakov it's a pleasure to be
here thank you very much for hosting me
here and uh indeed you're so right
enlargement is at the top of the agenda
of this commission and this is one more
reason reason why I'm very happy to be
here today uh thank you very much for
the excellent talks we
had How
[Music]
committ
Country different topics
in both make happen that's basically
where
[Music]
congratulations also on your
100%
you are a valued member of nat without
any
question mess is
that should be fully
focused we the
last bring it over the
fin um I'm very much looking forward to
meeting
that the whole
country is blessed with a very diverse
societ for justice and prosperity for
all
the European Union
ised
mess our economies
[Music]
closer
interconnection mon has the
poti we also went through the energy
we can see
together let's look at the economy of
today and
the
that the European Union
the second element is the Western
[Music]
Balkans um the common regional market
has
potential completed it could increase
the the third element is single
Market um you will have to deliver these
reforms to accompany these reforms uh
this is for example for monteno to
um with that we are able if we do it
right and open our
economies principle investment and
reforms
[Music]
time
uh rtcg public broadcast we heard from
president milatovich that Montenegro
could become an EU member State even
before 2030 so what's your opinion how
realistic is that yes um there's no need
to
[Music]
wait I see it on the political
side if you theary
conditions
there is no need to wait to a certain
date it's not driven by a
calendar delivering ofs and maturing of
the society and the economy toward the
European basically to fulfill the
criteria M states have to fulfill to be
this
this this will open the door
for
Montenegro is a democratic
country Mon's
Choice choose its
leaders
institutions strongly believe in the
ability of mon
convinced that you will show
that um and it is up to the people of
mon one we want to speak together
with
for
[Music]
uh
mon
[Music]
ER
Poli smarter decisions and adopt
policies that will actually uh result in
the overall progress in monegro as I've
said before I repeat it again uh
regarding census so my view has not
changed regarding the government I
think the fact that mono got the new
government is a good is good news and I
believe that um well I expect from the
government was I understood from the new
prime minister uh he publicly spoke
about it that the country should stay
strongly on its Euro Atlantic
course that it should strongly Implement
three priorities of our foreign policy
related to Credible membership of
Montenegro in NATO then true speeding up
of our European uh negotiations and
promoting good neighborly relations you
understand that part of the growth plan
for the Western Balkans that was
presented by the European commission is
also Improvement of regional economic
cooperation so I believe this is fully
in line with the third priority of our
foreign
policy also I do expect from the
government internally
to speed up the reforms in judiciary I
read in detail the expose by the Prime
Minister the part related to
improvements in the field of the rule of
law is best described and I welcome that
fact I also expect from the government
additional Improvement of the European
of the economic standard or the living
standard of the citizens increas in
wages and retirement benefits I think
this is an important issue for the Prime
Minister as much as it is for me and
ultimately I believe that we will work
together to build montro is a country in
which all of its citizens have equal
opportunities for
Success
uh the government will have the
strongest uh supporter and friend in the
president of Montenegro if it uh abides
by these principes principles that it uh
specified and I believe that it will
follow the path that it defined in any
case uh the appointment of the new
government is a good thing I welcome
that consolidation of the new
parliamentary majority in the parliament
is also a good thing and I expect from
the Parliamentary ma majority to achieve
political consensus when it comes to
appointments in the Judiciary you know
that appointments in the
Judiciary constitute the most important
thing that should open up and speed up
the the process of accession you know I
mentioned several times in the past that
a number of chapters are technically
ready to be closed but simply we are
awaiting stronger progress in the field
of Judiciary that is appointments in
judiciary to be specific and I believe
everything that happened yesterday in
today is good news consolidation ation
of the Parliamentary majority and the
appointment of the new government and
I'm pleased that the new prime minister
will have his actually first working
meeting with the president of the
European commission I believe this is a
very good
signal uh for Montenegro but also for
the
EU uh about this shared Vision which is
to achieve our European dream Mr
milatovich thank
you uh with this we end this press
conference thank
[Music]
you